remember when Saturday Night Live almost
reunited The Beatles or when Sinead
O'Connor got in trouble with the Pope
for a show that's been going strong for
almost 50 years it goes without saying
that its history is riddled with all
brands of controversy and Intrigue what
was that special
in 1974 Joni Carson was the biggest
money maker on television according to
the New Yorker he brought NBC about 60
million dollars a year which earned him
quite a bit of Leverage when negotiating
an extension on his contract to continue
making The Tonight Show the program
aired weeknights at 11 30 pm and back
then NBC filled the time slot on
Saturdays with a Tonight Show clip show
called The Best of Carson but when
Carson told NBC he'd only make four new
shows each week moving the best of
Carson to a weeknight he left NBC with a
90-minute hole in the Saturday night's
schedule the network decided to try out
a late night variety show geared toward
a young hip audience to run it
Executives tapped 30 year old Canadian
comedy writer Lauren Michaels best known
for his work on an emmy-winning Lily
Tomlin special it took Michaels a year
to work out the format and find a cast
of seven sketch comedians but in October
1975 the show was ready to go during its
first season on TV 1975 through 1976 the
show wasn't actually called Saturday
Night Live as that title was already in
use sportscaster Howard Cosell hosted an
ABC Primetime variety show with the name
and oddly enough future SNL star Bill
Murray was one of the stock players but
when that show was canceled NBC snapped
up the title replacing the Bland
original NBC's Saturday night that's why
at the beginning of each show a
performer says
[Applause]
and while the show's opening sequence
Now features the main cast and featured
players names read loudly and excitedly
by Daryl Hammond who replaced longtime
announcer Don Pardo after his death in
2014 the SNL cast members weren't
introduced individually during the first
season the Obscure comedians were
instead dubbed the not ready for Prime
Time Players but Dan Aykroyd Chevy Chase
Jane Curtin Gilda Radner and the others
wouldn't stay Anonymous for long
nowadays the show is pretty much all
comedy with a couple of musical
performances thrown in but in the early
years Saturday Night Live was a true
variety show The Muppets were frequent
guests on the late night circuit in the
mid 70s so it only made sense to include
them but we're not talking about Kermit
and the Gang here instead Jim Henson and
his cohorts created a whole slew of new
monstrous adult oriented creatures for a
segment called the land of gorge stick
my fingers in his ears
it might have been the first and only
time a Muppets project was not well
received considered not as fresh and
urgent as the SNL manic sketch comedy
the segment ground each show to a halt
and due to writer's Guild rules the
sketches couldn't be written by Muppets
writers leaving regular SNL writers to
do it and they resented the puppets for
taking up valuable air time the Muppets
were gone after the first season
for a Business Insider here's the
timetable for how an episode of SNL is
produced Monday the guest host arrives
at 30 Rockefeller Center in New York
City where SNL is shot they go to
Michael's office where they talk to
writers and cast members about their
comedic strengths Impressions they can
do and other suggestions writers then
pitch their ideas Tuesday as a holdover
from the show's cocaine fueled days in
the 70s writers spend all day and night
writing their sketches the host and a
cast member also shoot short commercials
to promote the episode they are edited
and put on the air within hours of being
shot Wednesday the table read is at 4 pm
every proposed sketch is included so it
usually takes at least three hours then
producers and the head writers determine
which sketches are good enough Thursday
at 6am Builders begin constructing sets
at a shop in the Brooklyn Navy yard at
30 Rock The Crew firms up plans for
costumes wigs and makeup any pre-taped
video bits are recorded Friday
rehearsals are performed and rewrites
are hashed out Saturday the sketch order
is sent and presented to a live audience
at 8pm any last minute changes happen by
11 30 PM when The Show Goes live
after one SNL season ends and another
begins at least a couple of Veteran cast
members decide to leave the series that
presents an opportunity for SNL brass to
bring in new performers which helps keep
the show fresh in terms of comedic
voices and styles SNL talent scouts and
producers find those Next Generation and
emerging stars who might be a good fit
for the show by casting a wide net while
they'll consider online Comedians and
take recommendations comedy hotbeds like
the Groundlings in Los Angeles or the
Upright Citizens Brigade in New York
often arrange showcases for top talent
and Michael's and other show staffers
writers and cast members attend if they
like what they see they invite the
performers to an audition on the SNL
stage hopefuls have 10 minutes to do
stand-up or present at least two
original characters and celebrity
Impressions I'm Penelope Cruz I'm always
searching for the most perfect
moisturizer with more than a dozen
performers and at least that many
writers in direct competition with each
other to fill just about an hour of
sketch time somebody is going to get
left out in his book gasping for airtime
former cast member Jay Moore said he was
so desperate to get a sketch on the air
in 1995 that he stole a routine by
comedian Rick Shapiro and turned it into
o'callaghan and Sun Pub two months later
SNL fired more and while Larry David
eventually went on to co-create Seinfeld
and star and Curb Your Enthusiasm he had
an uneventful spell as an SNL writer in
1984. back then only one of his sketches
made it to air an odd piece called going
up in it an architect becomes frustrated
that a client wants to make sure that
the elevators in the new building have
stools for elevator operators David
later recycled the bet for an episode of
Seinfeld
okay
not bad
it's obvious which guest hosts SNL likes
the most because they're the ones who
keep coming back Steve Martin Alec
Baldwin Woody Harrelson and Melissa
McCarthy are a few who have meshed well
with the program on the other end of the
spectrum there are hosts who will likely
never return because they were difficult
to work with obnoxious or both in a 1992
episode host Nicholas Cage confides to
Michaels that he fears he'll be the
worst host in the show's history
Michael's replies no no that would be
Steven Seagal Al Franken wrote that joke
but many SNL alumni including David
Spade have named the martial arts actor
the show's worst host but according to
Michael's the worst was probably early
TV star Milton Burl who guested in 1979
and disrupted the show with mugging
ad-libbing of old entire jokes and
arranged beforehand to have the studio
audience give him a standing ovation at
the end Tina Fey however didn't beat
around the bush when she told Howard
Stern who she thought was the worst
Paris Hilton
that's hot
while many of the show's performers come
from an improv comedy background it's
forbidden to improvise on SNL the show
has to be planned down to the second to
account for each sketch musical
performance and a commercial break but
not every host and musical guest follows
that rule and many were subsequently
banned in 2003 Adrian Brody did an
impromptu borderline racist bit with a
Jamaican accent while introducing Reggae
Singer Sean Paul in 1996 Rage Against
the Machine asked for two upside down
American flags to be hung on the stage
one producers said no the band hung them
up anyway stagehands tore them down just
seconds before they were supposed to
perform and their second song was
canceled the musicians were escorted
from the building before the episode had
even finished send dog of Cypress Hill
claimed his group earned a ban after
smoking marijuana during their SNL
performance and let's not forget Sinead
O'Connor's Infamous Pope incident in
1992. just because in SNL episode airs
it doesn't mean it stays that way
forever Purdue officers often Tinker
with shows for reruns replacing a sketch
that went poorly with a superior version
recorded during dress rehearsal that
means some lost sketches only survive on
DVD and streaming versions one of them
butt County dance party aired in 1976 in
the sketch a small town sheriff played
by Dan Aykroyd hosts a TV dance show and
winners get to have their names run
through a teletype machine to check for
outstanding warrants but when the
machine malfunctioned Aykroyd tried to
improvise and told everyone to keep
dancing although there was no music NBC
cut to random stock footage of car
crashes then pulled the sketch from
reruns in another instance from 1985 NBC
president Brandon tartikoff appeared in
a sketch to collect urine samples from
cast members for drug testing but it was
later deemed to be in poor taste in the
reruns it swapped out for an extra
musical performance by Simple Minds
for decades each episode of Saturday
Night Live has basically followed the
same format a bunch of Standalone
sketches a couple of musical
performances and Weekend Update
somewhere in the middle in 1986 that all
went out the window but just once to
cater to a very special guest acclaimed
director Francis Ford Coppola was the
host and the through line of the episode
was that Coppola was directing the show
the credits were stylized like those of
an art film and the music was provided
by that night's musical guest
avant-garde composer Philip Glass cheer
star George Wendt was on hand to deliver
the opening monologue and appeared in
sketches while Coppola didn't act in
anything apart from appearing as himself
sitting in a director's chair and
interrupting the show every few minutes
to critique the actors performances or
other aspects of the production Dennis
you can't do a satellite interview with
you know Shea it's too much like Ted Ted
kopel
sorry couple anyway it's not original he
also appeared in vignettes with
Michael's and cast member Terry Sweeney
to discuss innovative ways to save the
show which NBC was actually considering
canceling at the time
many of the most popular SNL characters
have been spun off into feature films
but very few of them have been
financially successful some of these
include the Blues Brothers and the
classic Wayne's World does this guy know
how to party or what it's the 100
million dollar plus box office take of
the latter that encouraged the
production of more and more SNL movies
in the 1990s and early 2000s A Night at
the Roxbury offered a look at the
backstory and home life of those unnamed
guys played by Will Ferrell and Chris
Catan who bobbed their heads to
Hathaway's what is love and tried to
pick up uninterested women in a series
of sketches in the mid-1990s it earned a
respectable 30 million dollars at the
box office in 1999 and so did superstar
about Molly Shannon's awkward schoolgirl
character Mary Catherine Gallagher
other films didn't fare so well it's Pat
revolving around Julius Sweeney's
character Pat Riley the joke being that
people couldn't figure out the
character's gender barely saw release in
1994. nor did Al Franken Stewart's
Smalley vehicle Stewart saves his family
the following year as of 2023 the last
SNL based movie to see a theatrical
release was met Gruber in 2010. not
every single aspect of Saturday Night
Live is produced as its live broadcast
since the beginning of the show in the
1970s pre-taped segments short films and
Commercial parodies have almost always
been a part of the SNL format Tom
Schiller produced Standalone films for
SNL in its early years such as the Flash
Forward death meditation Don't Look Back
in Anger They're All Dead
I'll tell you why
because I'm a dancer in the 70s comedian
and filmmaker Albert Brooks rejected
Michael's offer to make him the show's
permanent host and instead offered to
create short films mockumentary Master
Christopher Guest also contributed short
features as a cast member in the 80s
Robert smigel's animated TV Funhouse
Anthology featuring the ex-president's
fun with real audio and The Ambiguously
Gay Duo broke up SNL episodes in the
2000s and The Lonely Island brought more
than just Andy Sandberg to Saturday
Night Live they also brought comic rap
videos and viral hits like Lazy Sunday
and I'm on a boat in 2021 SNL brought on
the internet comedy troupe please don't
destroy to produce semi-weekly videos
for the show
once they've finally made it into the
cast of SNL the worrying doesn't end for
performers they can and have been
abruptly fired from the show Damon
Wayans told the Weekender of his
1985-1986 tenure they didn't let me do
what I wanted to do on SNL he got so
frustrated that he did something he knew
would lead to his termination he
deviated from script and rehearsal and
in a life sketch portrayed a police
officer character as a flamboyant lgbtq
stereotype in 1995 SNL cleaned house in
the wake of a blistering New York
Magazine cover story that hailed the
show's demise and as ratings
subsequently fell Michaels fired nearly
everyone including major standouts like
Adam Sandler and Chris Farley David
Spade Tim Meadows and a few others were
spared the next season Michaels brought
on new hires like Will Ferrell Jim
Brewer and Sherry Oteri and in 1998 NBC
executive dick ebersol who helped
develop SNL in the 70s fired Weekend
Update anchor Norm Macdonald reportedly
due to his constant jokes about accused
killer O.J Simpson Ebersole happened to
be one of Simpson's friends she
exclaimed he did it reach for comment
O.J said my mom was just guessing I
hadn't even told her yet more recently
Taran Killam and Jay Pharaoh were both
Lego after six years on the show
only a couple hundred performers have
ever been full-fledged SNL cast members
it's an achievement unto itself for a
young comedian if not a launch pad to
Future entertainment World success but
some people's time with the show ended
before it could even begin during the
1980-1981 season Emily Prager and Lori
Metcalfe joined SNL as featured players
a writer's strike ended the SNL season
prematurely at 13 episodes by which
point Metcalf had appeared in only a few
segments and Prager hadn't appeared at
all they exited the cast shortly
thereafter Emmy award-winning actor
Catherine O'Hara actually joined SNL in
the early 80s during a Hiatus from
Canada's SCTV and quite a couple of
weeks before the SNL season began airing
although she did go on to have a turn as
a host in 1992. O'Hara told the Toronto
Star I hung out with some nice people
tried to come up with some ideas but I
never really felt involved in September
2019 SNL announced that comedian and
podcaster Shane Gillis had landed a spot
in the cast within the week footage of
Gillis uttering slurs on his podcast
offensive to people of Chinese descent
and members of the lgbtq community
surfaced online and went viral days
later before ever appearing on the show
Gillis was fired
according to the New York Post six years
after the Beatles split up in 1970
concert promoter Sid Bernstein offered
the Feb for a whopping 230 million
dollars to get back together and go on
tour the band members declined but the
cultural incident was fresh in the minds
of Saturday Night Live viewers later
that year so Michaels went on camera in
September 1976 and pleaded with the
Beatles to reunite on his show and play
three songs for a comically small amount
of money and told them I was authorized
by NBC to pay them the sum of three
thousand dollars that was three thousand
dollars for just three songs it was all
a joke but unbeknownst to Michaels At
the time two Beatles actually considered
accepting Paul McCartney and John Lennon
happened to be together watching SNL on
TV at Lennon's apartment when Michael's
made his pitch McCartney told Rock news
desk John said we should go down just
you and me there's only two of us so
we'll take half the money but it would
have been work and we were having a
night off so we elected not to go
five years into SNL Michaels needed a
break in Casey departed entirely he
picked staff writer and cast member Al
Franken to be his replacement two days
before discussion with NBC president
Fred Silverman Franken appeared in a
weekend update segment called limo for
the lame-o criticizing Silverman for
charging NBC for car service despite the
Network's failures the guy's been here
two years and he hasn't done didley
Squad
and he gets a limo now that enraged
Silverman and led to such animosity
toward SNL that Michaels wound up
leaving the show altogether NBC
appointed inexperienced TV producer Gene
dumanian to replace Michaels her first
task hire new performers as most of the
old ones left with Michaels dumanian
hired stars like Eddie Murphy and Joe
Piscopo while the show cycled through
writers during the 1980-81 season SNL
lost 30 percent of its audience while
critics lamented the slide in quality
the 11th episode of the Season featured
an extended Riff on the who shot Jr
storyline from Dallas with cast member
Charles rocket foe shot during the
show's good nights guest host Charlene
Tilton asked a wheelchair-bound rocket
how he felt he said it's the first time
I've ever been shot in my life I'd like
to know
[Music]
one episode later NBC fired dumanian
soon after that rocket was let go as
well a rider strike followed and the
season ended early
Saturday Night Live is a high-profile
Pinnacle of Comedy but it's not for
everyone now best known for Strangers
With Candy and BoJack Horseman Amy
Sedaris was performing her comic stage
show one woman shoe in 1995 when
Michael's approached her about replacing
abruptly departed cast member Janine
Garofalo Sedaris told writer David
rakoff it was everything I wanted maybe
even three years earlier it would have
been great right around the time she
landed a breakout role on friends in the
mid-1990s Jennifer Aniston met with
Michaels and turned down the chance to
be in the SNL cast she recalled telling
Michaels about the show's Boys Club
atmosphere during an appearance on the
Howard Stern Show I didn't think I would
like that environment Johnny Knoxville
passed on SNL in two different ways
Knoxville and a team of skateboarders
put together a pilot of themselves
performing wild humorous pranks and
stunts that project aired on MTV as
jackass after Knoxville turned down a
weekly spot for the concept on SNL
because they'd have more control over
the material on cable SNL then asked
Knoxville alone to join the cast he told
the Washington Times it was at the point
where I either say yes to my friends
where we had all the control or yes to
Saturday Night Live where none of my
friends were really going to be there
and I had no control
Saturday Night Live writers are
unionized and part of the writer's Guild
of America when the organization goes on
strike it ends production on most
scripted television series two such
stoppages resulted in unique Saturday
Night Live presentations made by SNL
cast and writers and presented live but
never aired on TV according to the war
for late night book when the 1988 writer
strike caused SNL to wrap up the 1987-88
season early writers Robert Smigel and
Bob Odenkirk took all the sketches they
didn't think would ever make it into a
broadcast episode of SNL after
recruiting future writers Conan O'Brien
and Greg Daniels the group put on the
happy happy good show at a theater in
Chicago among the sketches in the
presentation was Chicago super fans
which would later be a recurring SNL bit
called bill swersky's super fans
responsible for the catchphrase
[Applause]
during the 2007-2008 wga strike the
Upright Citizens Brigade theater in New
York hosted a complete SNL episode for a
live audience with proceed needs
benefiting furloughed SNL staff most of
the show's regular cast at the time
including Fred Armisen Seth Meyers Daryl
Hammond Keenan Thompson and Amy Poehler
participated Michael Sarah served as
guest host and Yola Tango was the
musical guest because of the writer
strike the sketches were written months
or years earlier all of them consisting
of things rejected for the TV version of
SNL
it's not uncommon to meet a romantic
partner in the workplace and Saturday
Night Live seems to be the kind of place
where people make lasting love
connections Star Wars favorite Carrie
Fisher hosted SNL in 1978 and met Dan
Aykroyd there but according to aykroid
their romance began while filming The
Blues Brothers Scarlett Johansson hosted
SNL in 2006 when Colin Jost was a writer
on the show and they worked on a sketch
together in 2010 when Johansen returned
by 2017 they were an official couple
they married in 2020. and I met the love
of my life here
writer director Dave McCary helmed the
SNL short Wells for boys during an
episode hosted by Emma Stone whom he'd
later marry when Mad Men star Jon Hamm
hosted SNL in 2008 he brought along
co-star Elizabeth Moss for a cameo in a
sketch where she met fellow cast member
Fred Armisen the pair married in 2009
and split up in 2010 cast member Cecily
Strong dated featured player and writer
Mike O'Brien in 2014. Pete Davidson met
comedian kazzy David when her father
Larry David hosted the show in 2015.
Davidson broke things off in 2018 and
Days Later began a relationship with
Ariana Grande whom he'd first met when
she appeared on SNL in 2016. Davidson
later enjoyed a romance with Kim
Kardashian whom he connected with after
her 2021 hosting stint
alongside the ever-changing cast of
actors and comedians on Saturday Night
Live each week as the Show's house band
a collective of experienced professional
musicians spanning many genres a number
of major stars have spent some time
playing the SNL opening and closing
themes jazzypop interstitial tunes and
sketch accompaniment music as required
Howard Shore who'd later go on to win
Oscars for two the Lord of the Rings
movies wrote the SNL theme song and
served as the Show's first musical
director following collaborations with
Lauren Michaels on Canadian variety TV
shows the 1972 Toronto production of the
musical God spell involved future SNL
grades Gilda Radner and Martin Short
while Paul Schaefer played in the
orchestra before joining the SNL cast as
an actor and before a 33-year stint as
David Letterman's band leader Schaefer
played keyboards in the SNL band
guitarist GE Smith became moderately
famous as a member of Daryl Hall and
John Oates backing band during their hit
making days in the 1980s but needed work
when the duo called for an indefinite
Hiatus in 1985 that's when Michaels
returned to SNL after his own Hiatus and
according to the morning call he asked
Smith to be the show's band leader
still photography comprises a big part
of both the look and flow of Saturday
Night Live and transitioning to and from
commercial breaks SNL puts up photos of
each episode's guest host generally of a
humorous and Whimsical nature since 1999
SNL official photographer Mary Ellen
Matthews is the person responsible for
those bumper celebrity portraits
Matthews takes the job seriously aiming
to make the host comfortable enough to
let loose and be creative she told
vulture I like to make it as easy as
possible for everyone I don't want them
overthinking this part of the show it
should be super fun and super easy it's
an open invitation to get kooky the SNL
production schedule is so tightly packed
that Matthews and a handful of costume
and prop assistants get no more than 90
minutes over the span of two days to
shoot an entire episode's bumpers about
four or five different visual scenarios
which makes proper planning key Matthews
added we tried to find out who's hosting
as far in advance as possible so we can
start thinking about it
in 2021 Lauren Michaels told reporters
that he might be winding down work on
the comedy institution my plan to be
here for the 50th and by that point I
really deserve to wander off Michaels
doesn't want SNL to end with his exit
however and he claims to have secretly
selected his successor less than a year
later Charlemagne the God reported on
his show hell of a week a rumor that NBC
may pull the plug on SNL when Michaels
Leaves after season 50. hell of a weak
guest Keenan Thompson the longest
tenured cast member in the history of
the show didn't deny the gossip there
could be a lot of validity to that rumor
because 50 is a good number to stop at
you know what I'm saying